hello out there time once again for the
movie retrospective I'm so happy to be
doing this movie because this is a movie
that I have loved since I first saw it
in the late 80s mid to late 80s and I've
watched it over and over and over again
and I was like really happy to revisit
it it's also a very fortuitous timing on
this because not only is it the week of
April Fool's Day this review will
actually go up a couple days after April
Fool's Day but I just found out that
scream factory just released this movie
on blu-ray for the very first time just
a couple days ago March 24th so this is
April Fool's Day a 1986 sort of slasher
now I'm gonna tell you right up front
that I'm gonna spoil this because you
can't talk about this movie to any
significant degree without spoiling it
yeah you know what I mean
you know you can't really kind of talk
about its impact and stuff like that one
thing that I always liked about this
movie and I actually wrote like a long
blog post about this a couple years ago
where I talked about this a little bit
is that in a lot of ways this movie is
kind of like ahead of its time yeah
because look at the [ __ ] that happened
like you know slashers and they had kind
of even by 1986 when this movie came out
um they were a little bit kind of you
know fading out of you know I think the
heyday of the slasher movie was probably
like early 80s yeah you could see
everything come as roses formulaic
yeah it's getting this kind of stale
yeah and so there weren't really that
many of them are not many good ones like
after like the mid to late 80s we still
rented him anyways well yeah I did too
but um you know but then there was like
a big resurgence you know when Wes
Craven did scream in 1996 with which
sort of it didn't exactly it was like a
parody of the genre but it was like a
meta type of thing and he also did a new
nightmare which was also kind of like a
meta-narrative and stuff screen was also
real high-end it had good actors in it
you had a mean and good-looking chicks
you know and [ __ ] it was well written
the humour was right and it was shot
real well so scream was that was a hit
from what I remember it was a massive
hit
well and it was really really um
influential yeah you know which I think
any horror fan would would your was that
you said Kay 996 that came you okay yeah
it seems like it seems like it dance
harder believe it was that long ago I
really I love scream and like I even
like some of the some of the sequels but
I didn't really like the newer slashers
that came out in the wake of it I just
felt like they they were trying to rip
that off well not only that but it's
just like they all seemed like some of
those horrible 90s like party of five
type shows like it was like friends but
it will be yeah it's like it's all
seemed like super slick and it's like I
just wasn't into it like I was a
one-shot deal
yeah though there was some there was a
couple of sequels to scream that I think
we go okay from yeah I just said that I
said I actually liked some of the okay I
think there were four were there four of
them I can't remember yeah I'm pretty
sure I've seen them all come became kind
of like Naked Gun or airplane where it
was you know Amanda how it was like a
good comedy series yeah yeah um there
was the thing to where they had like the
scary movie franchise which was a
straight-up parody run of not just
scream but like of the horror genre
general so it was just like a parody
yeah you know what yeah I was thinking
more of that that's was thinking more
than I actually didn't really the first
one was okay but those I didn't really
like just because it seemed like the
humor was just kind of like hey look
we're parroting this scene from The
Exorcist next scene I think you know
what I mean it's like okay a scary movie
parodied scream so much I got confused
about which one I was talking about yeah
I know that's a yeah yeah that's exactly
what happened it's great I've seen this
and scream is funny but it's like not
it's not that dating yeah so we went off
on that tangent just to say that as meta
as scream was and as you know as much as
Wes Craven gets a lot of credit for
going in this meta direction not just
with that but with Freddy you know the
Freddy Krueger of the new nightmare one
which was also kind of meta contextual
but April Fool's Day
kind of did the same thing back in 1986
this is kind of like and as I said if
you have not
it and you don't want me to spoil it
then we'll stop now because there is
just no way to talk about this in that
context without spoiling what happens in
the movie yeah I had never seen this
movie yeah I have seen it a million I
did really only in time I'm gonna tell
you right now I didn't have an emotional
connection to the movie I understand the
movie was important it was well-made it
had good cast that you'll recognize some
other horror movies I really didn't find
it that interesting but maybe now for
the same you know other people probably
would it just I guess it just depends on
your taste I mean it was a good movie
just what it just wasn't to my tastes
yeah I you know I feel like this one is
kind of like an underrated horror
classic now I even though the set up is
like a slasher and it was marketed as a
slasher even though the director was not
happy about that because he's like it
did well like financially but he's like
I think it would have done better if
they hadn't marketed as a slasher
because that's not exactly what it is
the setup is like a slasher and it plays
out like a slasher through most the time
but I would actually call it more of
like a mystery thriller yes
right because it's not real gory like
they don't really share are some like a
few gore shots but they don't really
show any the kills like everything is
off-screen but there is a reason for
that that you find out at the end of it
I think that's why it didn't really you
know push my buttons real hard because
it was like a mystery movie yeah and I
tend not to tend not to like those as
much yeah I mean if I'm gonna watch a
horror movie I want a straight-up horror
movie this one's good a different spin
on it and you're right it's a lot like a
mystery movie yeah and I would call it
that and actually the director Fred
Walton who actually he also did when a
stranger calls which was also kind of
like a more mystery oriented he also did
the Stepford husbands which I think I
talked about in our Stepford Wives
review but which I actually liked pretty
much although in defense of the mystery
genre we saw knives out I liked it I
thought even though I don't like Rian
Johnson what he did what he did to Star
Wars
I liked that damn knives out that was a
pretty good yeah well I loved his
[ __ ] hilarious
I like mystery movies yeah and so I kind
of liked this one even though like I
said this was marketed as a slasher it
looked like a slasher like from the
cover and everything like that oh it
looks
another one yeah a slasher when you get
in there it's not what it is but that's
not really what it is even though that's
how it plays out to do this thing so
like I said the end of this turns out
that the whole thing everybody getting
killed all the murders everything like
that was all an elaborate not well it's
an April Fool's Day prank so no one
actually dies in this movie um but what
it is it's it's a prank yes but it's
also the main character Muffy who's
played by Deborah Forman which I'll get
into in a little bit but she is um you
know she has is inheriting this huge
mansion and she wants to turn it into
like a country inn but like with an
interactive like murder mystery type
thing that you can pay and you can come
and do it so she's kind of invited all
her friends there to like do a dry run
through it to see if it will work out
like the idea that she has you know what
I mean cuz she so she wants it to be
kind of like a slasher themed murder
mystery weekend you know what I mean so
she's running through it with her
friends to see if it will work out the
way that she intended it to work out so
as I said nobody dies in this movie now
I think what I love about this movie and
I think I saw it so many times like in
the late 80s I first saw it on cable
like I think it was on Cinemax or
something like that
and I loved it the first time I saw it
and I taped it and I think I watched it
maybe once a month or maybe maybe once
every couple of weeks like for a really
long time because even when we rewatched
it last night I remembered every single
line of dialogue like at some point I
had like the whole [ __ ] thing
memorized one of the best things about
this is the cast this has a great
[ __ ] 80s classic ensemble cast
they're just all [ __ ] great yeah so
Deborah Forman is in this she's the main
character she was in valley girl which
is an amazing movie obviously one of
Nicolas Cage's early roles she was also
in my chauffeur which actually I
remember that being not too bad Amy
Steele is in this obviously from Friday
the 13th part to Ken ol aunt who is also
in summer school which is also a great
comedy if you want to see that cuz I
[ __ ] love that movie - he's actually a
producer now Deborah Goodrich who was in
just one of the guys
Clayton runner who was also in just one
of the guys and I was
liked him and I wish he'd had more rolls
he was in human centipede 3 though I
shouldn't say I didn't know there was a
cinema 3 yeah I couldn't get through
centipede 2 got about 15 minutes into it
was too slow I said advocate centipede
one was awesome though because I watched
it but I was just kind of like okay it's
girls whatever and also Thomas F Wilson
aka Biff Tannen from the Back to the
Future movies he was also in action
Jackson so there was another now I
didn't actually know this until I was
researching this for the movie but the
one actor that's in the movie Griffin
O'Neill that plays skip who you think at
the beginning is Muffy's cousin although
you later find out that he's her
actually her brother he's the son of
Ryan O'Neal and his sister is Tatum
O'Neal so I didn't like know that they
were related now I was on his Wikipedia
page earlier and they said he said that
Ryan O'Neal started giving him cocaine
when he was 11 years old and used to
beat the crap out of him and once shot
at him that's the kind of [ __ ] old
Hollywood used to be like that yeah yeah
although like I said Griffin O'Neal you
know the son who was in April Fool's Day
he was also accused of assaulting his
wife in 2012 and in 1986 the same year
this movie came out this movie has a
boating accident it
Griffin O'Neal accidentally killed
Giancarlo Coppola film producer in a
boating accident the same year that this
movie came out I blew my mind
Tatum on middle they said that they're
related right to Tatum O'Neal right yeah
she was my sister she was a bunch of
trouble too I mean she was doing drugs
by you know 11 12 years old oh they all
said that right O'Neal and yeah and gave
them drugs and stuff yeah and like Tatum
like I think she said that she was left
[ __ ] going to Hollywood sex parties
that like [ __ ] nine or some [ __ ] like
that
yeah it was like Drew Barrymore I think
it had a similar story
[ __ ] was been [ __ ] freaky there going
way back yeah and they were like little
kids yeah yeah so I thought that was
kind of interesting about the one cast
member in this yeah so like I said this
is a lot of great 80s heavyweights and
the coolest thing about this is that all
of the ensemble they
really well together because I mean I
love 80s movies I like 80s comedies I
like all the horror movies and stuff
like that and even ones that I like like
comedies and horror movies it's hard to
get a cast this large that actually
feels like an organic group or like a
natural group of friends but this
actually does you know what I mean
especially like kind of all the main
players there's just like all these
subtle little scenes with them like you
know the this scene with like the three
girls in the kitchen or they're taking
the Cosmo sex quiz and there's like just
all these little and the way that the
guys kind of like [ __ ] around with each
other and stuff like that it just seems
very natural which you don't get from a
lot of ensemble movies like this
particularly horror movies from the 80s
where it just seems like everyone's kind
of I don't know there's just like a
little bit of like over the top or
stagey or everyone's trying to be a
character you know what stood out for me
was that the the settings the settings
the clothes I mean if you like dead mall
videos and weird like a retro wave and
this [ __ ] is 80s as [ __ ] it houses the
house they were in was in this really
high end for the time you know kind of
mansion and I forgot how Queen and fake
British that [ __ ] Queen and decor
looked and even their architecture yeah
it looked like a mall version of some
from England internet [ __ ] yeah yeah you
don't see it anymore but when you see it
again on the screen you realize how out
of style that [ __ ] is you only see that
now and like an abandoned hotels
although it's a really great creepy
setting it this almost reminds me of
like a funny slightly slasher version of
like an Agatha Christie story like I
guess because of the setting I believe
they filmed this in an actual mansion
which was in maybe in Britain I think it
was in British Columbia like on an
island so I think the setting is really
good like I said the cast they all play
really well off each other it's funny
but the humor is like subtle and the
characters are all you know their
characters like in the sense that you
have like the kind of jock guy the kind
of the dudes are sort of douchey but
there's still but everyone is still
really likable which i think is kind of
like a hard thing to pull off but i
think everybody really does
that in this movie and you know you have
to consider these characters they're all
college students they're all like super
super rich and like super privileged you
know the girls been going to Vassar and
like all this other kind of stuff they
have this massive house and all this
other [ __ ] so we call them preppies back
in the day yeah so you can see how like
maybe from the outset you would think oh
these are gonna be unlikable characters
and you just want them all to get killed
but that's not how they come across even
the ones that are kind of douchey like
arches character like arch who's played
by um you know Biff Tannen Thomson
Wilson who's kind of a douche but he's
also kind of lovable you know what I
mean and they're all kind of like that
and I really like all the interactions
with them and some of the best [ __ ] in
it like I said it's funny but it's not
like zany funny like a lot of the humor
is kind of subtle or they just have like
these really kind of rye or like
sarcastic kind of lines and it just
plays really well a lot of the [ __ ] I
think is just really understated like
that and this is why you know when you
watch the movie and if you just think
it's a slasher movie that I can see you
getting frustrated because it like you
don't really get to see anybody get
killed it's like they always cut away
but then when you find out at the end
that the reason that they kind of ways
cuz no one actually got killed it was
all kind of like an elaborate like it
was all staged you know you you kind of
like should go back and watch it again
because there's so many little just
little one-off lines or like the way
they kind of look at each other it's
just you know there was one where one
part where Buffy who they think is Muffy
she is like saying how oh I'm not
worried about those two that disappeared
skip an art even though the guy's name
was arch she said it wrong but then the
other friend was just kind of like huh
that was weird but they didn't even
really like focus on it but then you
find out why later on because she was
pretending to be like an evil twin that
had killed Muffy this was Buffy and so
that that was like the the whole story
that she had concocted and she kind of
left clues around so that the final girl
kit played by Amy Steele would figure it
out at then so and said that's what she
was trying to establish by
putting all of her friends in this
situation she wanted to see if all the
clues she planted and all the [ __ ] like
that would lead them to come to the
conclusion that she wanted them to come
to now you have to like suspend your
disbelief a little bit because if
someone was really doing this like they
invited all their friends over for the
weekend to their families
humongous mansion and then they all
started getting killed one by one and
they think that there's a slasher you
know stalking them there were some
things and they do address this like
briefly at the end like when everybody
finds out that it's like it was just a
big joke and everyone's still alive you
know one of the guys says you know you
could have gotten killed because we
thought it was real and you didn't know
how we were gonna react and [ __ ] like
that
and she did address she's like oh I you
know I almost got killed on this one
because there was a snake in the woods
that bit tried to bite the guy and it's
like we didn't know that was gonna have
it happened and stuff like that so but
you know that's just kind of like a
minor nitpick I mean overall I just
always really really really loved this
movie and I think like I said it's down
to the cast and I really have to give it
props for being like I mean this premise
could have gone drastically wrong and I
think it got like I said it was
financially successful when it came out
I think it only cost five million to
make and that ended up making like at
least 13 million like in the theaters so
you know so that's a financial success
is more than twice but I think a lot of
people were frustrated because they were
like well they thought it was going to
be a slasher and it's not all that gory
and then at the end you find out it's
like oh just kidding
and some people were kind of like oh it
was like a it was all a dream ending but
in a way I think this movie was really
ballsy to just like commit to that
premise like all the way through like
nobody got killed
you know it's called April Fool's Day
for [ __ ] sake so I respect that they
actually took that premise and stuck
with it because now there was another
version apparently there was another
version of the ending shot where you
know yes you find out that all the
murders were fake but then skip the one
character
played by Griffin O'Neal there there's a
version of it where he actually kills
Muffy his sister for real to get the
inheritance and they were gonna end it
like that now Paramount Pictures who put
this out because this was the same
production company same producer that
did Friday the 13th which is why they
got Amy Steele to be in this because
some of the same people were involved
behind the scenes but Paramount said you
know it's like this has been such like a
fun light-hearted kind of movie up to
that it's like they thought it would be
kind of a bummer like to end it after
you know all the murders were fake but
no oh no there's a real one at the end
so they took that part out now the
novelization does have that um and I've
heard I didn't even know until today
that there was a remake of this movie it
was made in 2008 and I think it went
direct to DVD I haven't seen it but by
all like every other review I've seen it
seen of it has said it's just terrible
most people even said it was worse than
the prom night remake and I'm like wow
that's pretty bad but um but I haven't
seen it so I don't know apparently they
went that direction the remake went that
direction where there was an actual
murder at the end even though all the
murders leading up to that have been
faked but I'm glad in some ways I don't
like a lot of studio meddling because
usually it's for the worse but in this
case I think it was the right decision
because the whole premise of the movie
is that it's all a joke and I would have
been kind of disappointed if they had
been like oh okay no it's really a
slasher movie and we're really gonna
kill somebody at the end because we
don't want everybody to get bummed out
or feel ripped off because all of them
were fake you know what I mean I feel
like this is almost kind of like a meta
meta slasher because when you watch a
slasher movie um you know contextually
in the movie the murders are real but
they're not they're fake it's a movie so
I feel like I like that this one was
kind of like honest about that you know
what I mean because it's like you know
one of the guys in there's like he's the
special effects guy he helped Muffy set
it all up and he had like all these
[ __ ] appliances like on his face what
looked like his eyeball was popping out
and [ __ ] like that so it's like this is
almost like the most honest slasher ever
made
because no one actually died in it and
it's like it's almost kind of like it's
it's showing like the strings are
showing like that behind the scenes just
in universe you know what I mean yeah
maybe that's like kind of too deep for a
movie like this but I mean well that's
how I kind of took it anyway that's why
I was delighted by by finding out that
it was all fake at the end I just
thought I I'm a because the characters
were likable and I don't want him to get
killed
unlike the Friday the 13th movies where
I'm just like yes please just kill them
quickly like that I can understand I
understand why you liked it why it's an
important movie to me I didn't really do
much for me but it was a well made movie
yeah it's it looks really cool and like
I said I would call it more just you
know if you're gonna see it and
obviously you know you've probably
already seen it otherwise you know I
just spoiled it for you so sorry about
that but I would not call it a slasher
movie and like I said the director would
not call it a slasher movie he was
making like a fun like suspense thriller
you know with some comedy in it that was
kind of like it's not exactly parodying
slasher movies although it does do some
[ __ ] like like it throws a cat at one of
the characters and stuff which i think
is a direct parody of that [ __ ] scene
from Friday the 13th part right where
that's where the cat comes in yes they
do [ __ ] like that yeah but I think they
do it you know they don't do it in a way
like hey look what a joke this is but
it's like I just think the fact that
it's in there they were just kind of
like winking at the audience kind of cuz
they yeah because they had seen that
because they had seen that movie and it
was the same production company so I
think they were kind of like oh moshing
that right um I don't think it was meant
to be taken seriously but you know the
thing I like about this one like I said
it's that makes it not exactly a parody
cuz like I said I didn't like you know
the scary movie like those parodies just
because they seemed really witless and
it just seemed like it seemed like not
jokes it just seemed like here's like an
over-the-top parody of this scene from
whatever movie and then they just moved
on it did another one it was just like a
bunch of like dumb set I think the time
and the target audience is very young
though yes yes definitely
this one the humor is a lot more subtle
the humorous it's like they're all so
like all the characters I think I said
this in my blog post like all the
characters had these like ridiculous
like waspey names like Muffy st. John
pretty repulsive yeah it's like but but
like I said it kind of works because the
characters are still like pretty are
still likable even though they're these
super privileged like rich kids talking
about those comedy movies though a scary
movie an air planet what's weird is that
humor age is very badly I just don't I
mean some of the [ __ ] that I thought was
hilarious back in the 80s you go back
and watch it you're like it you can't
get a laugh out of you I guess the
Overton Window changes so much about
what's funny what and what is it you
know I mean like I remember how
outrageous Eddie Murphy was his stand-up
to act Bueller hear it now and you can
hear that anywhere just way everybody
talks yeah I mean it was shocking at the
time shocking at the time you didn't
hear it on you didn't hear it on
television it's good you know it's just
kind of the same thing with seeing
horror movies it's like you have to see
things in the context of when they came
out it's like if you see like psycho
nowadays it's like nobody thinks that's
super gory but back then it was like
really shocking but could no no one had
ever seen anything like the shower scene
before yes well a lot of things don't
age well they don't but if something can
last 20-30 years you know it was
timeless is the [ __ ] timeless classic
yeah if it can last that long
most [ __ ] ages out within 3-4 years yeah
but that's why I think this one kind of
holds up still because they weren't
trying too hard with the humor like a
lot of the humor just comes from like
just random like funny [ __ ] they say to
each other they're not it's not trihard
yeah like the scary movie you know
franchise seem to be very trihard like
they were screaming in your face this is
funny you know what I mean and I don't
really like that type of thing I tried
to watch Mel Brooks history of the world
and if she wasn't funny I got about 15
minutes in and I go man oh [ __ ] this is
not although I must say that Young
Frankenstein is still funny they're
still funny yeah histor the world's not
funny I haven't seen it since I was I'm
glad it burned it out cuz I've seen it
so many times and maybe it's funny when
you're a kid so you're so amped up you
know Brooks was on so much coke maybe he
just had to be just like totally coach
to the gills to think that shit's funny
I don't know maybe but like ice
some of his movies are still funny
Blazing Saddles - still funny Young
Frankenstein is still funny that was a
good movie uh I think space balls are
still funny
I haven't seen an forever that was funny
at the time actually but yes so you know
humor subjective obviously but I always
liked April Fool's Day because it's
clever its self-aware but it's not
pointing a finger at it's self-awareness
which I think screamed it and I love
scream but scream was like very overt
about its self-awareness and what it was
doing and like how it was trying to be
ironic this one not so much
um you know a lot of it like I said it's
just very understated but there's like a
lot of humor like in a lot of the little
subtle interactions and like [ __ ] going
on in the background like different
things that characters do and stuff like
that
so as I said if you haven't seen it it's
I'm glad that it's finally getting like
a [ __ ] nice blu-ray release because
prior to this I don't even think yes it
was on VHS cuz you know it was in every
video store had great cover with that
[ __ ] braid with the noose you know
really iconic but up to this I think it
didn't even get like a DVD on its own
until 2013 prior to that it kept getting
thrown on discs with like other movies
you know what I mean like it was on a
like a set with My Bloody Valentine you
know cuz April Fool's Day in My Bloody
Valentine I think it was on like a disc
with graveyard shift that [ __ ]
Stephen King movie with all the rats and
tales from the dark side which is
actually a good movie but so I'm glad
that like scream Factory
good old [ __ ] scream factory man
they're so rad they just released this
on blu-ray and hopefully I don't know if
there's gonna be a lot of special
features on or something I might have to
pick this up because I want to see like
some behind the scenes [ __ ] cuz I really
do love a lot of these actors you know
what I mean especially Debra Forman and
she's [ __ ] great in valley girl and I
told me he'd never seen valley girl
either I'm like you definitely have to
see [ __ ] valley girl oh I'm excited
about seeing that oh good punk rocker
does he act crazy as [ __ ] um does he
cage the [ __ ] out not well he's real
young so he's not kind of I don't know
he's kind of crazy in it but not like
Mandy crazy you know he's kind of more
like
awkward a little bit but also super cool
here's another plug if you guys haven't
seen Mandy and you haven't seen color
out of space
[ __ ] they're streaming to see that
[ __ ] I think shudder has shudder has
them both right
well shudder has Mandy and it just has
Mandy doesn't have the color out of
space because we thought that color out
of space was on Xbox that but yeah pay
for that yeah they have it those two
movies are awesome cage cage in the [ __ ]
out that made by the same company
they're both really good movies I
probably would watch Mandy first but I'm
just surprised that you'd never seen
valley girl considering Nicolas Cage was
in it
I mean came in on 83 [ __ ] great
soundtrack to I don't remember
maybe if I saw it again maybe there's
some that they had on it's like a teen
romance type of thing but it's like
easily one of the best ones of the
agency I liked it better than like some
of the John Hughes movies 83 I was
getting ready to go to Brazil yeah so no
I didn't I didn't see that yeah because
then once I got in Brazil they would
play that in Brazil that was that's
America specific yeah so I never got to
see that one it is it's an American as
[ __ ] them yeah but yeah it's definitely
a good one but yeah if you if you
haven't seen this one I really recommend
it if you like slasher movies or
especially like underrated slasher
movies like it it's not gory it's you
know there's not like a lot of nudity or
anything like that but it's are just a
really good like mystery and it's and
it's fun you know I mean it's a fun
movie it's got a great [ __ ] eighty
specific cast you will recognize pretty
much everyone in this movie from other
movies of the 80s if you're into that
kind of thing and they just play really
well together and it's just it's just a
really really fun movie like I said I've
seen it probably a zillion times and I
still think of lines from it you know
randomly and I was like happy to get to
see it again and I was like god dammit
this is like the perfect week to do it
because it's just coming out of blu-ray
and it's April Fool's Day week so yeah
but definitely I would definitely
recommend it Tom didn't really give a
[ __ ] about it but but I really like it a
lot so yeah